definition number two I'm just going to
give you the algebra for it okay the
absolute value of a is equal to the
square root of the square okay hmm
square root of the square of a that's a
bit of a funny definition because it
depends on something else obviously what
is it doing it's kind of doing the same
thing this is doing right because when
you square it when you square numbers
you lose information about them namely
you don't know what direction they were
going in the first place because
negative 5 squared and 5 squared have
the same value right so because these
are equal to each other it's like I had
information here and then it was lost by
squaring okay which by the way is a
lesson for later on when you're solving
equations and squaring loses information
that you used to have okay so that's why
sometimes you lose solutions you also
gain solutions if that's another of the
story the square root square root by
definition not this definition but by
its own definition is always positive
okay
so that's why you square it alright so
for example if I was to do that let's
let's take this definition and I'll
finish explain this first and then I'll
answer your question and let's do this
the absolute value of negative 3 this
time okay so this is the square root of
negative 3 squared which of course we
know is the square root of 9 which is 3
and only 3 not nor it's not less you
square root right want me to find this
it's only positive ok it's only positive
as opposed to so you know this this is
what I've just established okay if I
were to give you a different scenario
right this scenario this is a perennial
problem okay here's an equation and you
see why I keep on banging on about
kicking out things visually okay what
does this equation mean this is a
problem when is that parabola
intersecting with the line 25 the answer
is in it is X twice at
- and sorry negative and positive five
okay whereas if I said to you what's the
X is equal to the square root of 25 okay
this thing here is just a single by
definition yeah I see the actual graph
of this looks like that right and 25
would be somewhere along here and then
the square root of 25 oh yeah all the
way down yeah I just I just switched the
axes around I mean my scale makes more
sense if you think of this is 25 and
that is fine
that's that's the square root of that's
what this way makes looks like logs logs
we look very similar but they are
different okay so I'm glad we clarified
that everyone makes sense this is this
is our definition here okay let me just
underline it definition one definition -
I'm going to give you another one that
seems even more technical okay number
three I'm gonna leave you for all that
fun definition number three this time
I'm going to borrow from the language of
what we call piecemeal functions
piecemeal functions piecemeal means
things in parts okay so I'm going to
draw a big curly brace like that
indicated that the absolute value is
equal to two different things at two
different times okay so here's what I
mean yasuno of a whatever a is it's just
equal to a if a is greater than
everything zero okay I'll give you an
example a second if it's not fitting
this condition
what's the opposite of this condition if
it is less than zero right so if a is
less than zero for instance if it were
negative three right then the absolute
value a is not equal to a it's equal to
negative a that make sense so in other
words this really means two things
depending on where you are okay
depending on the value of a if you're on
this side then your this if you're on
that side then you this okay just a
quick note see how I've got the UM the
boundary the zero on this one and not
this one doesn't matter can you see why
it doesn't matter okay so number one I
just need to include all values I have
to capital number two zero is signless
it doesn't have direction okay
so it doesn't matter which way I go zero
negative zero same thing okay so that's
not arbitrary it's just that it can be
either of them